um welcome everyone this is the meeting
of the Northeast Irish District
council's cabinet it's the 26th of
January
um the first item on the agenda is
apologies for absence have we received
any
um
councilor Renwick and Council of Foster
thank you very much
uh any Declarations of interest from
anyone
no okay uh minutes the last meeting are
we happy to approve them as a true and
accurate record I'll happily move them
thank you second councilor Powell all
those in favor
okay that's carried
and then we come to developing business
support services and environmental
health and I'll hand over to cancer keep
it
thank you thanks chair
um hopefully quite a sort of
self-explanatory
um report but the the main aim of this
is to look to well to start to look to
expand
um the sort of environmental health that
support that we offer particularly for
businesses uh enumerate and therefore in
relation to pest control so as per the
two recommendations
um at the moment environmental health
have very close connections with
businesses both through the sort of
regulatory uh sort of necessity but then
also through uh sort of advising and
helping particularly new businesses but
also existing businesses things like
Pest Control you know and sort of
maintaining that side and then also sort
of food standards and food standard
inspections so uh we're noticing
um given the sort of increasing sort of
smaller businesses which is a good thing
in the district that there is a higher
demand for advice and support as
businesses set up particularly in terms
of that regulatory side and the food
particularly the food safety side and
then also a demand for
um Pest Control in relation to
businesses obviously we provide it um on
the household and sort of individual
basis but not for businesses and I think
there is a market there to be able to
support businesses in that regard if
they want it whilst being played with
you know we're not seeking to compete
with um sort of any existing firms
um so that's that's the purpose of the
report is to sort of explore that
further and to introduce it in a small
way uh and and sort of be able to
support businesses in our district
um particularly as the environmental
health Team I think you know we're in a
much better position now uh to what we
were a few years ago given the
investment that we've made in the
service and the recruitment that we've
had so I'm happy to move to
recommendations I don't know if Ken or
anybody else has got any of the comments
uh Joe the only thing I would add to
that really is just to be really
specifically clear that this isn't about
charging for anything that we currently
provide because it's really important
that we're clear about that it's about
additional advice and support and
additional services around patch control
brilliant thanks Ken
um any other comments from you
no not all happily second I think it's a
good good paper and definitely going in
the right direction with it so
um support that and we'll move to the
boat all those in favor
okay that's carried and then we come to
the medium-term financial plan and I'll
hand over to uh Jane first to give us a
bit of an overview of the paper
future yes so this is the um medium-term
financial plan for the period through
from 22 23 to 26 27.
um this so the purpose of the report is
to seek approval of the budgets for that
pit for the budget for next year and
those future years contained within the
plan
um I'm not going to go through all of
the detail because I know that you've
studied this at length and the
recommendations will be referred through
to Cabinet but just to pick out the key
highlights for you the national
settlement figures that have been
included in the mtfp for the next four
years contain rollovers for the next two
years
um but there's less certainty for future
years in the plan new homes bonus and a
selection of other grants have been
included including the new third tier 33
funding guarantee business rates are in
as previously planned part of the
Derbyshire business trades pool and the
those growth has been included in the
forecasts there's quite a lot of talk in
the mtfp this time about the economic
and fiscal Outlook which of course has
had a massive impact on the budgets this
year we've got high inflation in there
we've got Rising interest rates and
that's led to higher than forecast pay
settlements and significant in increases
to our energy costs for my teeth then
we've also seen quite a lot of increases
to our contractual spends and that's led
us to a position where we can balance
our budget in 23-24 but we are using our
resilience Reserve to do so the the
impact of the energy costs were just too
severe and too Southern for us to be
able to identify long meaningful
efficiencies during that time so the
plan is that we will use the efficient
the resilience Reserve to meet those
efficiencies to balance the budget and
then what we'll do as we always do we
will seek to find those efficiencies in
year and on a more long-term sustainable
basis the future years of the plan 24 25
isn't looking too bad at this moment in
time
um 25 26 onwards start to get a little
bit more difficult because of the
removal of government funding however I
do reference in the report that is where
the funding reforms to be um implemented
in 2526 there is the likelihood that
there will be some damping payments and
that would help us through that
transitionary period
um household tax is recommended to be
set at three percent which is the
maximum that we could go to this year
um based on the fact that we've got 12
inflation running through the budget
that that helps but it doesn't solve the
short form
um just briefly under the HRA the HRA
isn't under quite the same pressure as
the the general fund um but it's still
experience all all of those same
external pressures so it's extant it's
experiencing pay inflation particularly
contracts inflation around some of the
building contracts and that has resulted
in as increasing retinals management fee
Through The Negotiator process in the
contract
um Rick Nord have done a considerable
amount of work to limit that increase
through their own efficiency Savings in
the year
and with respect to rent um
considerable amounts of work's gone into
this looking at the affordability and
how much we should be increasing the
rents by The Regulators advice that we
could go to seven percent
um the lowest my advice would be that
you could go to is four percent but that
makes me somewhat nervous because it
doesn't build in any any sort of
resilience in the year and on a 32
million pound budget you need some
resilience
um so the recommendation of five percent
was being endorsed at this stage and
that will go to through to council for
approval on Monday
and I'm happy to take any questions oh
I'm going to hand over to Casa Kenyon
now
I believe through the chair much
uh any questions first before we move on
oh thank you very much for your
comprehensive thanks Jane over to you uh
Jeremy yes um thank you Jane for that um
yeah it's uh not a lot to say because
it'll be all gone through again at full
Council but it is worth saying we're in
a strong position financially much
stronger than some other uh councils
might be and that's down to a lot of
very hard work by officers so thank you
very much for for getting us into a
position where I'm not having to stand
up and deliver a load of horrible bad
news
um
and the only other thing I would say is
it's a very difficult Balancing Act uh
obviously there's three percent 2.99
council tax rise that's in the paper is
way below inflation that's that's really
difficult but it's a balance there even
more so on the HRA the rent figure
you're bouncing out uh future investment
providing decent homes with
um affordability for our residents and
we've chosen what we believe is the the
best possible that balance that we can
in the circumstances we all know about
so I'm very happy to move the
recommendations in the report
thank you cancel again absolutely agree
with you it's always a difficult balance
on these uh on the budget and whether
it's council tax or rents we've always
got a balance
um you know people's back pockets and
and you know challenging Financial
circumstances with our own challenges
and the need to continue to invest in
services and and the condition of our
housing stock and I think on the whole
we've hit them hit the mark right in
this in this paper and in these
recommendations and we've got to
remember that inflation is way above
what we're that the percentage increases
that we're talking about so uh
definitely I think it's the right thing
to do and and clearly we can't stand
still or go backwards so uh this is the
best the best of a difficult set of
decisions really
any um any other comments for me
no if not we'll go to the vote then all
those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
uh and then on the agenda
uh we just have urgent items of which
there are uh none so declare the meeting
close thank you everyone for your
attendance and look forward to seeing
you soon